[Music]
mmm
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
bleacher reports pregame picks the only
show in the world where you
the people at home can win free cash
prizes by simply predicting all the
random [ __ ] that occurs in the nba
pre-game
i as always am your host pierre aka
people the plug and i'm joined by my boy
my brother the one and only famous los
lose was cracking with you brody
what's up p i feel good today man how
you living
no i'm good i feel good i'm ready to
give away some money my boy
we're live from los angeles the staples
centers let's get to these pics baby
[Applause]
[Music]
yes
how crazy is that he's showing off the
money with this look we always keep it
clean
step first wow my name is i told y'all
welcome to pregame pics
let's get it
yes sir we back what's going on lost
talk to me i ain't seen you in a minute
man i ain't gonna lie mystery we be
doing our thing up here
how you been since the last time i saw
you what's new
oh i've been good man i've been good man
you see my loss i lost a thousand
dollars to max and ping pong but i did
beat him in the three-point contest so
you know
got my face back i feel good what you
want what you been doing uh
uh uh i'm good i'm prepping this friday
my b day coming up as i told you in the
pre-production
but i've been i've been staying off your
page a little bit cause i saw you with
that little mouse i don't do mice
that's not my style so i had to that's
not a mouse that's a hamster that's a
hamster
that that's a hamster she has she has a
name
what what's the name you didn't tell us
remember we have fans voting can you
announce the name
before we get into what we get into
diamond
diamond i need a cup yeah diamond
i got a cousin i got a cousin named
diamond so i ain't too mad at you but
lois before we started well before you
got on here i know you were you know
doing your thing for a second we was
asking the fans
who should lebron pick first for his
all-star team
you know he got a pick out of the
starters who should he pick first and
why
you tell me who you would pick if you
were lebron and why
and everybody in the comments let me
know who y'all would pick as well
talk to me lois come on you know who i
picked
you know who i pick i'm picking that man
i'm picking that man
the chef steph curry
hey refresh my memory real quick
has lebron and steph been on the same
all-star team yet since they've been
picking these teams and all that
i can't remember i want to say i want to
say last year
i want to say last year but but brian
had kyrie so they couldn't been on the
same team
that's what i'm thinking you know what
y'all got to correct me i can't remember
i
hey i can't i can't remember you to let
us know in the comments if you can't i
i'm not gonna lie i think brian out of
all the all-star starters
brian might pick kyrie that's just the
type of dude brian is just to be funny
let me get carrie but i would not mind
seeing chef with him
him and chef on the court together shout
out my boy steph
you know come on man you gotta go step
you gotta go steph
that's only a a fool doesn't go stealth
oh
only a full window stuff because katie
is sitting out kd's sitting out damn not
in a three-point contest and zion not in
the dunk contest hey [ __ ] just got real
this week too i just let y'all know what
was up
oh we are we gonna talk about that
please believe we're gonna talk about
that
but yeah yeah yeah but before before we
talk about that
guys the first thing that we got for the
people to win some money first and
foremost
we are sending five people home with
this first prompt that we have with 500
no matter what the result is five people
are going home
with 500 the first thing we're gonna
have
is will lebron make five and a half
threes
in warm-ups it's over or under do you
take the over which i know lose that
sometimes confuse you which means he has
to make six
or will he make under five threes in
warm up
lois you tell me what you're picking guy
guys the people in the comments
and tell them which way they should be
going sway them
this is tough this is tough this is
tough this is tough but oh my god this
is tough p
you might gotta leave you might got lead
this will be what you thinking what you
thinking
well listen last time
lebron left a little early lebron is a
guy that's kind of cool he's going to be
going through the motion so i'm going to
go under
i'm going to go under i'ma go you know
what let me revert back let me revert
back i'm sorry
i'm sorry i'm gonna go over i'm gonna go
over lebron is gonna hit six threes
in this one six three he's gonna go is
he even gonna take
is he even gonna take six threes that's
the question yes
yes yes this he's a grown ass man this
ain't zion
and the other people we've seen before
who steal on their young boy stuff
lebron focus and ready he know what he
got to do
he takes brian first of all first of all
brian should be first of all brian
should be
ron should be working on post phase and
free throws brian should be working over
yeah
should be working on free throws during
pre-game and not threes
brian threes has gotten better not the
free throws after
after the last laker game that we did
you saw the clip that bluetooth report
took and put on socials it was a three
lebron hit
yeah yeah you talk about that lucky [ __ ]
you talk about that lucky [ __ ] when he
was out of battles
stop it he need to work on the free
throws he needs to work on them free
throws game shots
bro i need to work on game shots let me
know in the comments what percentage
lebron's shooting from the free throw
line
i guarantee it's above 75 percent
i guarantee you this is not that
percent okay enough lebron because we're
gonna talk about lebron
i wanna talk to you about the all-star
weekend the dunk contest when we was
growing up
the dunk contest was the main event we
know that this year is gonna be a little
different we only got three contestants
this is that's very weird to me
but out of who we got yes who you got
[ __ ] who you rocking with
who you rocking with i saw you with you
later
yeah i don't even know who in the dunk
contest who was in a dunk contest
we got obi topping from the new york
knicks we got cash to stand
from the indiana pacers okay and then we
got anthony simons from the portland
trailblazers
he'll look guard but he got bunnies oh
bunnies i'm going with my i'm going with
my young boy i'm going with my young boy
cassius
i'm going with cash yeah cash has got
cash he get up there hey hey hey
and anna and i didn't say his name here
duke boy
hey but i just got word that cast has
had zero dunks
this season he still ain't done that's
light that's a lie
that's a light that's a light that's a
light that's a light i just seen him
dumb
that's a lie do you want to see the
chocolate jacks on it
do you want to put jumping jacks on it
yes while this is going on type in
type in nba cash is dunk
i'm gonna type in right now and listen
while i'm typing this up to look it up
i want you to know i'm rocking with my
boy you know i'm a nick fan i'm rocking
with ob
topping they nobody on out duncan will
be talking
nobody out ducking i'll be talking nah
but if the knicks doing that with that
that's good to bring back to the city
that's good to bring back to the city
they're gonna make playoffs and win a
dunk contest that's stupid for the city
y'all
you see what happened with bobby out
bobby out buy me out
hey bobby hey hey
cass is cast his dunks is all preseason
he don't he don't
he don't get oh yeah yeah bobby out free
fail though let all of my dogs out
cashes don't have no dumb yeah while i
when i talk to you about the next
the next all-star uh event i need my 50
jumping jacks
please sir please oh you 15 so i'm gonna
do i'm gonna do my 15 right here
wait how you know how you know they all
uh pregame
because they tell you they tell you to
date and what's that okay
the season they don't yes they do it's
right here it's say december 14th
december 18th the season will start to
the 27th
yeah yeah get him off look look at her
her boyfriend her boyfriend on the phone
like hey you been i say nothing to bro
you've been out looking bro i'm not
gonna say nothing i'm i'm in my seat no
i'm chillin
her boyfriend know who she came from she
got a son shirt on she came for that boy
book book she came for books
look it oh he definitely gonna kill him
he's definitely gonna kill her you know
you know
for the mix dudes you know you'll be
ready to kill the mix dude
babe i'm not going to say anything to
him relax
i'm just here with my friends yeah yeah
she's wrong
hey listen speaking of phoenix suns i
want to give a shout out
you know i'm always repping the home
team yes sir
i love it hey i'll tell you guys
he's a bucket he's a bucket that ain't
your cousin though stop it you're
capping ass
that's literally my cousin when me and
you got on tnt
he hit me
you owe me a thousand you owe me a
thousand jumping jacks
no that's literally my cause it's not
just because
his mom that's your mama cynthia is my
auntie
bro hey y'all this is a joke
this is a joke
i see you say legend come on man hey
lois lois one thing about me
i ain't gonna lie to you i ain't gonna
lie to you hey
i ain't gonna call him call him call him
right now
call him right now and tell him uh to
let us know when he walking out the
locker room
i bet you he'll pick up your child
you're gonna try to get my boy suspended
monty williams gonna tell his ass hey
next three games you're ain't suing up
you know not to answer that phone call
while we doing warm-ups
come on now who marty
williams right
right now i do 150 jumping jacks while i
talk for the rest of the show
called trends you gotta do the 150.
150. the sun's
walking out so trays might answer but
the sun's not walking
out right now hey family
[Applause]
i'm on tv right now and i told him you
was gonna pick up we watch it out look
we watch y'all month
no way no way hey i told you i told you
he's gonna pick up
told you he was gonna pick up ain't
nowhere in hell he just picked up
because that boy is right there
in the in the line and we we got the
lebron you don't see him
officially you don't see him you don't
see him you don't see him
bro did he just answer the phone oh
sorry
keep it above yeah was that trend i'm
keep counting for me yes it's crazy man
two okay brian hey made three pointers
one just threw that jersey like that i
would've caught that jersey ran up out
of there with that thing that's that's
it that jerry's worth some bread
i hope you know those two pause loss i
hope you know we about to go viral
that they bout to make a big deal out of
how to
answer that phone that better go viral i
need y'all to
y'all tweet that out 50 times this week
please
nah we lit we lit come on man phone call
phone call you got to pick up i'm
motivating hey
when i call pick up i'll say hey i need
4 dogs i need a pink pink
i need i need bro you want me to call
bruh
life brian got his life life bar i got
his phone in his pocket
life brian got his phone in his pocket
trent just made me so happy bro
yeah trey's a real one for that i gotta
give me my trench my treasure is herald
jersey lebron ain't attempting no three
yet come on bro
don't send me wrong don't get me wrong
everybody
everybody in the comments let me know
which way y'all going over under on the
price
he's just shot in the five people home
with 500 dollars
let me go i got to give you at least 20
more pause
he just he just shot at three but he
missed it
hey let y'all know he's doing these
push-ups because he didn't
believe me because he didn't believe hey
come here color
hey i'm hey who are you with who you me
i'm a man of my word
[Music]
hey phoenix we got all the all styles
you want to be an all-star come to
facebook
yes sir dude go right there go right
there man
go right there i'm gonna come with you
yes sir do your bonding press do
do your broader impression man run out
light brown
[Laughter]
what did we do my boy bro
my boy brian duncan right now so now
i'ma ask you for the next one because i
got it all in front of me three-point
contest you rocking with your boy steph
we got steph donovan mitchell uh tatum
jaylen brown devin booker and zach
levine
come on come on
i gotta go with steph i can't i can't go
with nobody but steph but steph
lost my money last time so i really want
to go with devin booker but i can never
go against that
and devin booker look like your cousin
uh that's what i was gonna say though
stefan steph is the easy answer but it
ain't a guarantee can step for superstar
he might chill he done one before he's
not
as hungry so you gotta go with somebody
that's
hungry exactly just another i'm going
zach levine
zach levine first time at all-star he
hungry he ready for the stage
what he's been waiting for his whole
life give me zach levine in that
three-point contest
and if i win i need 150 jumping jacks
like i just did
and it's just i would do that shout out
my boy wallow
yes i would do i would do i would do 150
jumping jacks for 10 minutes straight if
if
that exact exact uh win
so i'm a little upset man i'm a little
pissed off because lebron ain't hit a
three yet
right now we're trying to send five
people home with 500
on lebron over or under did we go over
threes
and warm up i went over he hit him you
went under
you went under all right yeah regardless
we sent it back regardless
five people getting sit home with five
hundred dollars
oh my god hey wait that dog did that
count what's that
that's not that's not a three though
that's not a three can i see it one more
time
can i see it one more time because if
come on that long that might need to be
changed
why is he shooting mid-range shots bro
doing long tunes man i told you
he needs to be working on long tunes and
and free throws
maybe baseline floaters
wait is that a three let's see let's see
let's see that's a three that's a three
major two then it looks good hey can we
get another angle
oh no we don't need another angle
that's good yes we do that they're gonna
drop it
look at mine let my up down good
oh now they hit the top of the corner
that one don't count
up down let's go that's full let's go
come on bro split cat boy that's five
[Applause]
lebron happened to be one of them look
at him look at him look
that's for my boy pee wee the plug
that's what that smile was so
because of that we're gonna be sending
five people home with five
hundred dollars whoever was who was
rocking with me
on the over on five and a half threes
for lebron james jubilee was going home
with five
hundred dollars loss tell these people
what to do with their five 500
500 invest in invest in your craft
whatever you do invest in your crap you
make music yes sir
live video buy videos y'all do kd
buckets
katie bugger camera yup
go ahead kd buckets michael uh trailer
curtsy uh cam 75 loreno
invest in your craft like lo say listen
to uncle low
go do something for your crabs so you
can take that 500 and double up like my
boy nipsey rp
nip so the next thing that we got
devin booker's final shot whether it be
a jump shot or a layup slash dunk
talk to me los which way you going with
this one damn well devin booker
hey hey no more easy [ __ ]
we getting hard now pause damn
i don't even know if i should be saying
paul yeah what did you let me stop what
did you
say what the freak did you it's getting
it's
it's getting tough it's getting tough
well devin booker last shot be a jump
shot
or a layup slash dunk
i need no thoughts uh a jump it's going
to be a jump shot
if if we lose this if you lose this it's
so me gang it's so me gay it's on me
game
okay it's gonna be it's gonna be a jump
shot i'm gonna go lay up
yeah hello
but we got we got we got nine minutes we
got nine minutes to find that out
yeah it may be a jumper you're right
he's a jump shooter what's your thoughts
on d
book being a snug now we we know he made
it
technically but he didn't make it the
way he wanted to make it he would snub
we gonna we gonna call it how it is
we me and you're gonna all if there's
one thing me and lo's gonna do
if it's two things we're gonna do we're
gonna entertain you and we're gonna keep
it real
what's your thoughts on d-book being
snuck talk to them
this is the thing if he got snubbed okay
be with my boy
if he got snubbed who who got in there
that wasn't supposed to be in there
pause
that's the question that's the question
everybody's thinking
the argument that's a fact the argument
was
him or chris paul
that was the argument i was saying they
teammate
comment both of them thriving the sons
the sons ain't where they at without
either i know chris paul did come and
help there's nothing to take away from
chris paul
he's going to do that he's a hall of
fame point guard he's going to make your
team better
but that team ain't like that without be
booked
listen cp3 is a veteran he's a vet
in the game he they they have to put him
in there they're gonna
they have to put him in there that's
just that says they did that that's what
they did because he's the vet
that's why they put him in there just
you know be real
you know he got he got the uh
he got the grounds when it come to that
not no young boy not no young boy book i
don't give a damn
i don't give a damn if book have 73
oh oh hell no if books out 73 he ended
up
over over cp3 that's what i was gonna
say
i was gonna say forget what they saying
i want to know what loss would do if you
had one spot left for the all-star game
and it was between devin booker and
chris paul in 2021
which one you picking don't try to duck
my my question you gotta pick one devin
devin paul
[Applause]
they say they say the state farm
commercial that chris paul be doing
homie looked like devin booker that's
that's my god dude though i can't
remember his name he was showing me love
at the game with uh that's my dude he
was helping me out
in one of the all-star games producer
dan want to know do he look more like
devin booker or drake
devin booker or drake the dude from the
state front commercial he looked more
like uh
yeah cj cj
looked more like cj watson in the face
yes now
i got it i got down though i got to see
yeah i got to go look at cj watson
i ain't seen cj watson in a minute shout
out tj watson used to play for the bulls
you know what i mean when i was growing
up watching the bulls and they should
they uh
they play off runs he looked like cj
watson in the face
yeah damn nose below nose and under
nose and under hey hey little show i'll
tell you
and he got the cj watch the haircut and
he got this
hey you [ __ ] dude you're a real
golden state warrior fan
giant cj watson what's your name what's
the wrong with that boy big 30 curry
first of all and first of all i'm a
bucket fan i'm a league fan anyway i
watch the game i know who nice bro
i know who nice it don't matter about
you ain't got to be popular for me to
know you nice
hey i just i just got i just got a big
update
devin booker has left the court so we
have to review his final shot to see if
it was a
jump shot or a layup slash dunk can we
get a drum roll please
and see what devin booker last shot was
come on let's go drumroll because i know
it was a jump shot i know it was a jump
shot i know what the jump shot
was a jump shot watch watch
[ __ ] [ __ ] uh
out of here hey if you went with lois
you are a winner good call know below
the winner baby shout out my boy d book
shout out hey lost let's go we sending
five we sending five people home with
200
because of that shot i do want to wait
for the last four minutes though just in
case he come back
out there and that go your boy tries
tres is on the floor now
there he goes finally there you go he
gonna put it he gonna put in work
he gonna put in work tonight too pause
these
we got sports feeds i think i know
sports fees shout out to sports feeds
we got brandon uh i can't pronounce your
last name but brandon you know you got
that money
willie boy one on one and we got mikey
or mike
youngster 23 make sure y'all get into
them bleacher report apps
check your dm so you can receive your
money those are our five people that are
going to be taking home 200
yes sir congrats to y'all make sure
y'all invest that money into y'all crabs
like my boy losses
now lost back to what we was talking
about
we may be going viral for that moment
you just gave us man i can't believe he
answered that phone
i got i got i got to get credit wiz too
man
i would've i would have put about a
shuttle camera but i ain't doing all you
know i ain't doing all day i did it
yeah my boy up got my boy i put the
steak on the stove and he got to grill
it right now bro he got his business
it's time it's time to cook
right now watch him he from no camera
stupid yeah
we we ain't getting nobody in trouble
that's one thing we ain't trying to do
but
i gotta give you your credit you got
support you guys are poor shout out hey
shout out my boy
shout out my boy tht chicago
representative we got a lot of chicago
in the house tonight a.d with chicago
representing
tht chicago representative frank kamiski
i played against hammer high school
chicago representative javon carter my
blood cousin
chicago representative proviso east yeah
yeah
a lot of chicago on the beach yes sir
chicago is the basketball
first of all don't you ever i love
chicago to death i love chicago
yeah don't don't say that north carolina
north carolina is the basketball state
and don't you ever forget it
don't you ever forget it listen don't
you ever all love to north carolina i've
been in north carolina
a couple years ago for all-star weekend
it was beautiful i love j cole
i love the baby mvp but chica chicago is
chicago is crushing north carolina dog
are you serious
name somebody from north carolina that
can even that could be in the same
conversation with derrick rose i'll wait
what what do we get do we get jordan
no no no we don't get jordan
how are we gonna get jordan jordan
hey you can't tell nobody from you can't
tell nobody from no kill out of that
you can't tell nobody from north
carolina we don't get jordan
but we can't oh but but but you can't
dead rose
hey where you've been told
what i'm gonna give to chris paul i want
the people at home to put in the
comments where they think michael jordan
from
are you considering in brooklyn new york
which is what a lot of new yorkers will
say
or are you taking lows and you're going
with north carolina
and now chris paul to get on chris paul
listen chris paul his prime
north carolina derrick rose in his prime
derrick rose boy are you are you
[ __ ] are you really drunk bro
are you really drunk bro i'm taking
drunk i'm taking prime derrick rose
over prime chris paul any day of the
week
you know you heard me um
in high school recipes is grandfather
but uh yes most epic
legendary most legendary [ __ ] i've ever
seen in my entire life
you you know derrick rose the youngest
mvp ever
ever yeah hey john wall hey and john
wall too we got a number one
we got another we got a number one two
john wall two we got number one
i love john wall i don't even want to
get up here and say nothing
disrespectful i love john wall
what are you talking about unless
something [ __ ] come out your lips
he's number one
what are you talking about andreas chris
andres
anthony davis is a chicago
representative
don't don't get me started we got them
boys
and if you want to talk high school
basketball jabari
hey congrats congrats all the people
that want money today
uh all of y'all that you're called 500
for the lebron challenge
all y'all that took home 200 for the d
book challenge shout out my boy lose
forgotten y'all in the right direction
that's what he do
um hey man it's always a pleasure man
you know we do this thing the right way
man another another good one another
good one who you got your bread on uh
who who winning who winning tonight
lakers or or or phoenix you going with
uh devin booker
your cousin you going devon booker your
cousin lebron
i'm rocking with cuz though man i'm
rocking with phoenix you
i love brahms it's all in the family
it's all in the family who your cousin
who your cousin again carter who your
cousin again carter
yeah i'm going with you already no
that's not
that is not your cousin but i'm going
with my trash harold man
hey montreal tonight i'm gonna get hey
and he ain't gonna have 15 minutes
report yeah bleach report y'all put this
clip out java gonna tweet and say that's
kuzzo
yes sir hey
hey and we better we better than 500
sit-ups
love y'all we out yes sir
we out
[Music]
so
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
you